let's now discuss the ties and you often  you will adjust a little bit more to the  client office or what the clients is  doing if they're wearing ties then you  will likely wear a tie as well so if you  do wear a tie similar with the other  things I would choose more plain more  regular colors so here for instance dark  green dark blue some very light more  decent motives surely are okay as maybe  here you see this very light green and  blue motive that you see here on this  tie but this is what I would go for  surely I would be a bit careful when  your Motors are more colorful more  playful maybe like something like this  this would be a more sportive tie the  problem is not the best fit for  Consulting